the opening scene we are introduced to
Captain vikrant Kana a renowned and
skilled pilot known for his courageous
emergency Landings currently in Dubai
vikrant arrives at his hotel after a
successful landing and receives a call
from a friend who invites him to a club
initially vikrant declines the
invitation saying he has a flight to
Cochin scheduled for the next day
however when his persistent friend
continues to insist he gives in upon
entering the club vikrant notices his
friends staring at a beautiful woman
whom he considers to be out of his
league but vikrant is certain that he
can seduce her with his good looks so he
proposes a bet saying he can get the
woman's phone number if he loses he will
buy his friend a car but if he wins he
will take his favorite motorcycle these
guys live on a different planet Earth
than I do the friend promptly agrees and
so the challenge begins after drinking a
few rounds vikrant confidently
approaches the woman and entices her
with smooth talk then he gets her phone
number and convinces her to join him and
his friend for a party the three then
dance all night and have a great time
perhaps there's even an Eiffel Tower in
Dubai before returning to their
respective hotels in the early morning
unfortunately because of all the
drinking vikrant misses all his alarms
and falls behind schedule he is
eventually awoken by a call from his
wife who reminds him about their
daughter's upcoming birthday however
vikrant who is known to have an
exceptional memory assures her that he
knows the date very well as the time for
departure draws near vikrant hastily
prepares himself and makes his way to
the airport concealing his tired eyes
behind sunglasses upon arrival he meets
his co-pilot Tanya Albuquerque and they
briefly discuss their upcoming flight
they then engage in small talk before
boarding the skyline 777 aircraft once
everyone has arrived vikrant addresses
the passengers providing them with
important information about the expected
duration of the flight the distance to
their destination and the prevailing
weather conditions it's almost like any
other normal flight and the people
appear to be calm but once the plane is
Airborne and reaches suitable altitude
vikrant activates the autopilot mode and
goes to sleep can he can he do that
after a short period of time an engine
alarm begins to beep and Tanya struggles
to identify the cause fortunately
vikrant wakes up and quickly resolves
the issue using his sharp wet he then
calls over a flight attendant and
requests a cup of black coffee saying he
is still feeling drowsy he also Whispers
the name of a specific medication
which she understands and prepares for
him when vikrant finally receives his
coffee he retreats to the restroom
momentarily soon after he returns to the
cockpit yeah he does and engages in a
brief conversation with his co-pilot as
time passes it begins to rain heavily
with flashes of lightning and thunder
when the pilots check the fuel meter
they learn that the airplane still has 4
800 kilograms of fuel moreover they
estimate that it will take them
approximately 45 minutes to reach Cochin
meanwhile at the Cochin Air Traffic
Control Office there is an elderly staff
member by the name of Mr tripathy who
continues working despite his weak
Health as the flight nears its
destination Tanya contacts the coach in
ATC to seek permission for landing
however Mr tripathy informs her that the
heavy rain has significantly reduced
visibility on the runway leading to
negative response you're gonna have to
hold up dear upon hearing this Tanya
consults with vikrant regarding whether
they should proceed with the flight or
attempt The Landing she also lets him
know that their fuel reserves are
decreasing by the second but to her
surprise vikrant asserts that they will
proceed with the landing despite the
challenging visibility conditions Tanya
then relays this message to the ATC
notifying them of the critical fuel
situation as a result Mr tripathy
finally grants them permission to land
on Runway number 27. all right come on
in now it is only a few minutes until
the landing but the rain has become even
more violent this sadly causes the
aircraft to lose communication with the
ATC forcing them to abort the landing
and fly again in the next scene a
worried Tanya proposes to vikrant that
they consider Landing in Bengaluru as a
highly secure option she calculates that
they need 3 300 kilograms of fuel to
reach there and they still have 3 900
kilograms remaining however vikrant
disagrees and says that they will be
heading to their original destination he
then contacts the coach in ATC to seek
permission for landing a request that Mr
tripathy grants but unfortunately the
degrading weather once again blocks
their view of the runway now with time
running out and people starting to panic
Democrats swiftly Alters the flight
route to the adjacent city of trivandrum
the plan is to land there as soon as
possible however unbeknownst to him the
trivandrum ATC is busy informing other
airports to deny any flights Bound for
them due to an approaching storm at the
same time Mr tripathi's Health begins to
deteriorate I'm not feeling good and he
is replaced by another staff member this
staff member is unaware of the crucial
emergency information received from
trivandrum on the other hand anxiety
grows among the people awaiting the
arrival of their loved ones as new
spreads about the flight diversion
inside flight 777 the condition is even
more severe the passengers have become
Restless asking the flight attendants a
series of questions one of the
passengers on board happens to be an
aviation journalist who senses that
something is amiss when he informs the
others about it they all begin to panic
and start screaming the situation soon
gets out of hand so vikrant himself is
forced to come out of his cockpit and
take charge with a calm voice and a
raging boner he urges the passengers to
collab saying that they all share the
common goal of reaching the destination
safely meanwhile at the trivandrum ATC
the staff members are relaxed assuming
that no flights will be landing until
further notice but much to their dismay
they suddenly receive a landing permit
from Tanya who's aboard flight 777 the
staff nervously questioned her whether
or not they received the storm emergency
notification issued by the coach in ATC
they further explained that the
visibility on the trivandrum runway is
significantly poorer than in coaching
implying that it is impossible to land
they suggest Bengaluru as an alternative
Landing option but vikrant informs them
that they did not receive any emergency
notifications he also alerts them of
their critically low fuel level hearing
their conversation the inexperienced
Tanya begins to scream but vikrant
manages to keep her composed as the
aircraft nears the runway the turbulence
intensifies sending both the passengers
and the flight attendants into a state
of panic this finally convinces the
trivandrum ATC that it's now or never so
they Grant the aircraft permission to
land on Runway 2016 vikrant slowly
brings down the plane and attempts to
touch the runway but the wheels lose
traction forcing him to abort the
landing and Ascend once again following
this he informs the ATC that they will
make another Landing attempt but this
time on Runway 34 hearing this the ATC
officials become worried and question
the Pilot's decision revealing that the
wind direction on 34 is horribly
unsuitable for landing they anticipate
that the plane's tail may be ripped off
but vikrant still does not budge with
the fuel running out quickly he has to
take matters into his own hands after
preparing himself mentally if it Grant
instructs the passengers to hold on
tight as they are preparing for an
emergency landing he then shockingly
closes his eyes and Glides the plane to
the ground as safely as possible
eventually the aircraft touches down and
begins skidding it almost reaches the
end of the runway but fortunately comes
to a stop in the nick of time this is
how he touched down with his buddy last
night too in this way vikrant has
miraculously managed to land the plane
safely despite the extreme circumstances
however the complications do not end
there in fact they have only begun
vikrant and Tanya find themselves facing
an investigation by the directorate
general of civil aviation or the dgca
due to their extremely risky Landing the
dgca thoroughly examines every aspect of
the flight including the MayDay distress
signal issued prior to the landing
following the investigation dgca
officials relay the unfortunate news
that one of the passengers an elderly
woman passed away due to a heart attack
after this the investigation findings
are forwarded to narian vadat a strict
head of aircraft accident investigation
Bureau aaib he will now be in charge of
finding the culprits and punishing them
meanwhile vikrant struggles with guilt
as he blames himself for the old woman's
death he feels that he could have done a
lot better to help his passengers
shortly after vikrant receives a
distressing call from the deceased
woman's daughter who calls him a
murderer she mentions that people like
him should never be allowed to fly
aircrafts after the call and the grant
tearfully returns home where his wife
attempts to console him reminding him
that if he was not the pilot the
incident could have been even more
tragic meanwhile Marianne and his
investigative team examined the black
box and gather all the information so
that they can catch the guilty party
later vikrant receives a notification
from the aab summoning him for the
investigation that will take place the
following week then he gets a call from
narian who asks him to prepare for the
upcoming proceedings however vikrant
calmly responds that he has nothing to
prepare for as he has nothing to hide in
the next scene we are introduced to the
director of skyline Airways named
Nishant he appears to be happy due to
the substantial rise in his company's
share price following the earlier
incident however his expression quickly
changes when he learns that narian will
be the one leading the investigation
according to Nishant narian conducts his
investigations in a manner that leaves
no chance for the accused to escape
amidst these events the airplane
incident gained significant coverage on
television opinions diverge with some
blaming the pilot for the woman's death
and others commending their decision as
the best under those circumstances in a
fascinating twist none of those
commenting are pilots themselves the
scene then transitions to vikrant and
Tanya's first trial which is taken as a
high profile case Marianne asserts that
the captain was leading the flight while
it exhausted having undergone a week of
non-stop flights he explains that pilot
error is often stem from feelings of
homesickness however vikrant defends
himself by drawing a parallel with
soldiers who fulfill their duties
Faithfully despite being separated from
their families for long periods narian
then presents vikrant with a bottle of
disprin a medication accessible only to
cabin crew and Pilots he suspects the
vikrant consumed this drug and proceeds
to use a lie detector machine to prove
his point but surprisingly the captain
successfully passes the questioning
without any issues leading to an
adjournment of the first trial later
that day a meeting is conducted by the
skyline company where Nishant and other
higher-ups advise vikrant to remain
silent during the trial in order to
avoid jeopardizing the his reputation
however the captain refuses to comply
which prompts Nishant to threaten him
with blacklisting from the entire
aviation industry he also issues the
same warning to Tanya before storming
out of the place during the second trial
narian subjects Tanya to a series of
questions that leaves her struggling to
choose her words carefully under this
pressure she reveals that the captain
had red eyes before the flight and had
taken a nap shortly after takeoff
furthermore she discloses their
disagreement over selecting an
alternative Landing destination when
vikrant claims to have had sufficient
rest prior to the flight narian
unexpectedly presents the woman from the
Dubai Club she reveals that they had
been drinking and partying and Eiffel
towering until six in the morning the
captain does not deny her account and
explains that he still managed to rest
throughout the day he highlights that
the flight rules stipulate a 12-hour
drinking ban for Pilots before flying
and that the time difference between the
end of the party and the plane's takeoff
was approximately 15 hours which proves
that he hasn't violated the rules
unwilling to give up narian lists out
vikrant's mistakes from that day
including hovering over Cochin for 33
minutes and fueling the plane below
maximum capacity in response the captain
emphasizes that Pilots aren't rule
makers but rather rule followers and no
responsible pilot would risk the lives
of their passengers narian then shifts
his attention to Tanya who then
accidentally reveals the startling fact
that vikrant landed the plane with his
eyes closed this gives narian the
perfect opportunity to highlight the
captain's irresponsibility furthermore
he raises the issue of choosing the
wrong Runway with these points raised
the second trial concludes without any
defense from vikrant when he returns
home his wife accompanies him to the
house of the deceased passenger's
daughter while the vikrant is in a
terrible mood at the moment he offers
his heartfelt apologies to the
daughter's loss the third day marks the
beginning of the third trial just before
the verdict is announced vikrant
explains that he possesses a
photographic memory of Runway number 34
due to his Landing experience there to
validate his claim he requests a
reenactment of the flight using the
flight simulator the judge approves of
this and in the next scene we see
vikrant taking control of the plane with
a blindfold covering his eyes Marianne
is also there in the co-pilot's seat as
he wants to inspect everything carefully
but the his shock the Blindfolded
vikrant manages to land the plane
without even breaking a sweat finally
the judge comes to a conclusion and Mr
tripathi is dismissed for failing to
relay the emergency information well he
probably deserved it while vikrant and
Tanya's pilot licenses are suspended for
three months only additionally the aaib
announces a strict investigation against
Skyline Airways the scene then shifts to
three months later when vikrant returns
to flying at the airport a flight
attendant from Skyline approaches him
and confesses that she was the one who
had consumed the discipline out of fear
she reveals that she had wanted to
confess earlier but as a single mother
she was scared about losing her job
vikrant asked for Viagra after all
vikrant empathizes with her situation
and reassures her advising her not to
worry with this he proceeds on his way
and the movie comes to an end
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching